WITH JUST OVER SEVEN WEEKS UNTIL
ELECTION DAY, THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IS TRYING TO RECALIBRATE
ITS MESSAGE.
SO FAR THEY CAN'T SEEM TO AGREE
ON WHAT THE MESSAGE SHOULD BE.
JOINING US FROM SOUTH DAKOTA
REPUBLICAN SENATOR MIKE ROUNDS.
SENATOR ROUNDS, THANKS SO MUCH
FOR JOINING US.
LET ME START WITH IMMIGRATION.
FLORIDA GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS
FLEW PLANES OF MIGRANTS FROM
TEXAS TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD
WITHOUT ANY WARNING TO LOCAL
OFFICIALS.
I GET THE IMMIGRATION IS A MESS
AND HAS NEEDED REFORM FOR
DECADES.
THESE ARE PEOPLE FLEEING MARXISM
IN VENEZUELA.
MANY WERE FALSELY TOLD THERE
WOULD BE JOBS AND HOUSING
WAITING FOR THEM WHEN THEY
ARRIVED IN MASSACHUSETTS.
DO YOU SUPPORT WHAT ABBOTT AND
DeSANTIS ARE DOING?
>> THEY'RE DOING THEIR BEST TO
TRY TO SEND A MESSAGE TO THE
REST OF THE NATION ABOUT THE
PLIGHT OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE COMING FROM SOUTH OF THE
BORDER.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT 3.4 MILLION
PEOPLE JUST SINCE THE START OF
THIS BIDEN ADMINISTRATION THAT
HAVE CROSSED THE BORDER.
THEY'RE COMING INTO SOUTHERN
STATES.
WHAT IS A GOVERNOR SUPPOSED TO
DO?
THEY'RE TRYING TO SEND A MESSAGE
TO THE REST OF THE COUNTRY THAT
THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE, AND THAT
THEIR STATES CAN'T HANDLE THAT
TYPE OF AN INFLOW.
THAT'S AN EQUIVALENT OF FOUR
TIMES THE POPULATION OF MY STATE
OF SOUTH DAKOTA.
JAKE, IT'S MORE THAN THAT.
IT'S ALSO EVERYTHING ELSE COME
ACROSS THE BORDER AT THE SAME
TIME.
WE'RE 1200 MILES AWAY FROM THE
BORDER IN SOUTH DAKOTA, YET THE
DRUG TRAFFICKING AFFECTS OUR
STATE AS WELL.
OUR NATIVE AMERICAN POPULATION,
RESERVATIONS HAVE HUGE INFLOWS
OF DRUG TRAFFICKING COMING INTO
OUR STATE, SOME OF THE HEAVIEST
POVERTY AREAS IN THE COUNTRY.
IT'S AFFECTING THE STATES BUT
THE ADMINISTRATION ISN'T DOING
ANYTHING ABOUT IT.
>> AS I SAID, THIS IMMIGRATION
CRISIS HAS BEEN GOING ON
LITERALLY FOR DECADES.
THERE HASN'T BEEN A MAJOR
IMMIGRATION BILL SINCE RONALD
REAGAN WAS PRESIDENT.
AS YOU DID NOT NOTE AND I DID
EARLIER IN THE SHOW, ONE OF THE
BUSES SENT BY TEXAS GOVERNOR
GREG ABBOTT DROPPED OFF ABOUT 50
MIGRANTS IN FRONT OF THE VICE
PRESIDENT'S RESIDENCE, INCLUDING
A 1-MONTH-OLD BABY.
THERE ISN'T ANY HEADS UP BEING
GIVEN TO MAYOR ADAMS, YOU JUST
HEARD FROM HIM, OR THE
INDIVIDUALS ON MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
I GET THEY'RE TRYING TO SEND A
MESSAGE, TRYING TO GET THE
ATTENTION, BUT ISN'T THERE A
DEGREE OF TROLLING GOING ON
HERE?
DO YOU REALLY HAVE NO ISSUE WITH
USING HUMAN BEINGS, A
1-MONTH-OLD BABY, LITTLE KIDS TO
MAKE A POLITICAL POINT LIKE
THIS?
>> YOU HAVE TO PUT IT IN
PERSPECTIVE OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
AT THE SOUTHERN BORDER RIGHT
NOW.
THIS IS EVERY SINGLE DAY
THOUSANDS OF INDIVIDUALS COMING
ACROSS WITH BABIES.
THEY'RE COMING INTO THOSE
STATES.
THAT'S GOVERNORS ARE FACING THAT
NOT JUST IN TERMS OF 50 OF THEM.
THEY'RE TALKING HUNDREDS, IF NOT
THOUSANDS PER DAY.
DO ANY OF US LIKE THE SITUATION
THAT WE'RE IN?
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, I WOULD
SUSPECT THAT THE INDIVIDUALS IN
THE SOUTHERN STATES THAT ARE
TRYING TO FIND A WAY TO GET THE
ATTENTION OF THE ADMINISTRATION
WOULD LOVE TO HAVE OTHER
ALTERNATIVES TO THEM.
IT'S BEEN 606 DAYS SINCE JOE
BIDEN TOOK OFFICE, AND THIS
PROBLEM HAS DONE NOTHING EXCEPT
CONTINUE TO DEVELOP.
THIS IS A NATIONAL PROBLEM, AND
YET THESE GOVERNORS ALONG THE
SOUTHERN BORDERS ARE THE ONES
FACED WITH TRYING TO ADDRESS IT.
IT'S NOT JUST 50 OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS COMING ACROSS.
IT'S THOUSANDS, AND IT'S ON A
DAILY BASIS.
>> OF COURSE, THE IMMIGRATION
LAWS IN THIS COUNTRY DO ALLOW
PEOPLE TO COME TO THIS COUNTRY
TO SEEK ASYLUM.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THE LARGER
SOLUTION THAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN
HERE -- AND I DON'T KNOW THAT
YOU WOULD DISAGREE -- IS A
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION BILL
THAT WOULD INCLUDE BORDER
SECURITY AND PERHAPS IN ORDER
FOR THERE TO BE A COMPROMISE, A
PATHWAY TO CITIZENSHIP FOR
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN HERE FOR
DECADES.
IN THE MORE THAN 20 YEARS I'VE
BEEN IN THIS TOWN, I'VE SEEN
PEOPLE LIKE PRESIDENT GEORGE W.
BUSH, SENATOR GRAHAM AND SENATOR
MARCO RUBIO TRYING TO GET
IMMIGRATION WORK DOWN.
EVERY TIME THEY WERE DEFEATED BY
HOUSE REPUBLICANS WHO WOULDN'T
GO ALONG WITH A COMPROMISE.
WOULD YOU SUPPORT RESTARTING
BIPARTISAN NEGOTIATIONS TO TRY
TO FINALLY FIX THIS BROKEN
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM?
>> THOSE DISCUSSIONS ARE ON
GOING IN THE UNITED STATES
SENATE.
IN FACT, THE LAST TIME THAT
THERE WAS A HARD PUSH WAS IN
2017.
MYSELF AND SENATOR ANGUS KING
CO-SPONSORED THE MEASURE
TOGETHER ON BEHALF OF A
BIPARTISAN GROUP.
WE GOT 54 VOTES ON THE SENATE AT
THAT TIME.
THAT INCLUDED ADDRESSING THE
FOLKS THAT HAVE BEEN BROUGHT
HERE THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR
OWN, THE DREAMERS.
WE ADDRESSED CHAIN MIGRATION.
WE ADDRESSED A PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP OVER AN EXTENDED
NUMBER OF YEARS.
WE THOUGHT WE HAD A PRETTY GOOD
APPROACH.
NOTHING HAS HAPPENED DURING THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
YES, WOULD WE LIKE TO STEP
FORWARD AGAIN AND TRY AN
APPROACH AGAIN?
ABSOLUTELY.
DO WE HAVE TO ADDRESS IT?
YES.
DO WE HAVE TO HAVE BORDER
SECURITY BEFORE ANYTHING ELSE
CAN HAPPEN?
WE'VE GOT TO BE ABLE TO DEFEND
THAT BORDER.
WE'VE GOT TO BE ABLE TO MAKE A
BORDER THAT ACTUALLY WORKS.
OTHERWISE, WHY SHOULD PEOPLE PAY
ANY ATTENTION TO THE LAWS THAT
WE'VE GOT?
WHAT GOOD WOULD IT DO TO REFORM
THEM IF WE'RE NOT GOING TO
ENFORCE THEM?
>>> LET'S TURN TO ABORTION,
BECAUSE YOUR REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUE,
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM
INTRODUCED A BILL THAT WOULD BAN
ABORTION NATIONWIDE AFTER 15
WEEKS.
DO YOU SUPPORT THE BILL?
>> NO.
I THINK RIGHT NOW WE SHOULD
ALLOW THE STATES TO EXPLORE THE
DIFFERENT POSSIBILITIES ABOUT
THE APPROPRIATE WAY.
HERE IN SOUTH DAKOTA WE HAVE ONE
WHICH IS -- I ACTUALLY SIGNED
INTO LAW WHEN I WAS GOVERNOR
BACK IN 2005, 2006.
I THINK THE INDIVIDUAL STATES
WILL COME UP WITH A MULTIPLE, A
WHOLE LOT OF DIFFERENT IDEAS
ABOUT HOW TO APPROPRIATE DISCUSS
ABORTION IN GENERAL.
THEN I THINK THERE WILL BE A
CONSENSUS OVER A PERIOD OF
YEARS.
AT THIS POINT TO HAVE CONGRESS
STEP BACK IN AND TELL ALL THE
STATES WE KNOW BETTER THAN THEM
HOW TO HANDLE THIS IS PROBABLY
NOT THE RIGHT DIRECTION TO GO.
WE ACTUALLY LOOKED BEFORE THE
LAST DECISION, WE LOOKED AS A
GROUP OF US AT TRYING TO BAN ANY
ABORTION PAST 20 WEEKS.
WE WEREN'T SUCCESSFUL AT THAT
TIME.
I DON'T THINK ANY PROPOSAL TODAY
WOULD BE SUCCESSFUL IN THE HOUSE
AND THE SENATE.
I THINK A BETTER APPROACH
PROBABLY WILL BE TO ALLOW THE
STATES TO WORK THROUGH THIS AND
TO FIND THE APPROPRIATE LANGUAGE
ON A STATE-BY-STATE BASIS AND TO
FIND THAT COMMON GROUND.
AFTER THAT MAYBE CONGRESS STEPS
IN AGAIN.
AT THIS POINT I THINK THE STATES
ARE IN BETTER SHAPE TO EXPLORE
AND TO FIND THE RIGHT DIRECTION
ON A STATE-BY-STATE BASIS.
>> YOU'RE ON THE SENATE FOREIGN
RELATIONS COMMITTEE.
THE TOP REPUBLICAN ON THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE,
CONGRESSMAN MIKE TURNER OF OHIO,
TOLD ME HE DOES NOT THINK THE
U.S. SHOULD SWAP CONVICTED
RUSSIAN ARMS DEALER IN EXCHANGED
FOR JAILED AMERICANS IN RUSSIA,
PAUL WHELAN AND BRITTNEY GRINER.
HE THINKS VIKTOR BOUT IS TOO
DANGEROUS.
DO YOU AGREE OR DO YOU THINK THE
U.S. SHOULD BE WILLING TO MAKE
THE SWAP?
>> I'M ON THE ARMED SERVICES
COMMITTEE AND ALSO ON THE
FOREIGN RELATIONS COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE NOT HAD A CLASSIFIED
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT THE IMPACT
WOULD BE.
I KNOW THIS IS UP TO THE
PRESIDENT TO MAKE UP HIS MIND
AND WE PROBABLY WON'T HAVE A SAY
IN IT.
I'M GOING TO WITHHOLD JUDGMENT
AT THIS POINT.
I DON'T MIND BEING CRITICAL OF
THE ADMINISTRATION, BUT I DON'T
WANT TO BE CRITICAL OF THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THEIR
DECISION-MAKING PROCESS WITHOUT
HAVING ALL THE FACTS IN FRONT OF
ME.
>> ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR MIKE ROUNDS OF SOUTH
DAKOTA, GOOD TO SEE YOU, SIR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING US
TODAY.
>> THANK YOU, SIR.